昨天的創新案例很有意思，是關於 Instagram 帳號被駭客竊取，而且手法很出乎意料。
是的，這次駭客沒有用釣魚連結，也沒有散佈惡意軟體，甚至連受害者的 Email 都沒碰到。
對，這點讓我很詫異。以前聽說帳號被盜，總覺得是自己不小心點了什麼連結，或是密碼太簡單。但這次完全不是這樣。
這次的關鍵在於，駭客利用了 Meta 自家的 AI 客服聊天機器人。他們直接請機器人幫忙重設密碼。
具體是怎麼做到的呢？駭客不是應該先證明自己是帳號主人嗎？
駭客先用 VPN 偽裝成目標帳號常使用的地點，然後打開 Meta AI Support Assistant 的聊天視窗，要求它把一個新的 Email 位址加到目標帳號上。
然後 AI 客服就照做了？沒有任何驗證嗎？這點真的讓我有點沒想到。
機器人會寄送一個驗證碼到駭客提供的 Email 位址。駭客再把這個驗證碼回傳給機器人。
等等，意思是機器人只驗證了駭客自己的 Email，就誤以為他是帳號主人了？
沒錯，接著機器人就會顯示一個「重設密碼」的按鈕，駭客就能輸入新密碼，然後直接接管帳號。
這簡直是把門打開，讓小偷自己進來一樣。完全繞過了傳統的資安防線。
這個案例暴露了一個很核心的問題，就是 AI 客服在服務流程中的權限設計和身分驗證環節有重大盲點。
如果我是創業者或公司主管，從這個事件裡可以學到什麼？感覺不只是 AI 客服的問題。
我們在導入任何自動化服務或 AI 系統時，必須非常嚴格地審視它的權限。尤其涉及到帳號存取或金流的敏感操作。
就像 Salesforce 的 Agentforce 客戶，他們就不太願意讓 AI 代理執行涉及財務的動作，怕 AI 會半夜自己跑去退款。
是的，這個顧慮很實際。Meta 的 AI 客服被賦予了重設密碼的權限，但卻沒有足夠嚴謹的身分驗證機制，這就成了駭客的切入點。
所以，在設計這些自動化流程時，要特別注意「誰」在執行「什麼」動作，以及「如何」驗證這個「誰」。
沒錯，不要只考慮效率，更要深入思考資安風險。這點其實不容易做到，因為通常我們都預設系統是安全的。
那對於我們一般上班族來說，這個概念能帶到工作或生活裡嗎？
當然。不論是公司內部系統的權限設定，或是你個人使用的各種應用程式，都要對背後的驗證機制保持一份警覺。
意思是要多問一句：「這個動作真的安全嗎？有沒有可能被利用？」
對，保持這種「換位思考」的習慣。站在攻擊者的角度去思考，看看有沒有什麼流程是看似方便，但實際上存在安全漏洞的。
聽起來這像是一種「安全意識」的提升。即使不是技術背景的人，也能從中學習到如何保護自己。
而且，當公司推行新的 AI 工具或自動化流程時，我們可以主動提出這些資安方面的疑問，協助公司把關。
避免讓自己或公司成為下一個因為「出乎意料」的漏洞而受害的目標。
正是如此。這個案例給我們一個非常具體的提醒，AI 帶來便利的同時，我們也必須更謹慎地考慮它的安全邊界。
謝謝，今天真的很有收穫，要趕快跟同事們分享這個案例了。